natural moves  and magnus continuing with the threats  because now bishop takes c3 as an idea  and knight a2 yeah  egc3 capturing the pawn on c3 after that  so actually it's  already very  threat yeah  extremely difficult for napoli actually  to hold c2 to hold  both of those  knight d1 it looks so passive  after that right i mean it's ugly but  maybe you just need to if you want to  win this game  it looks like a dream opening from  magnus and  d4  so not afraid of push basics  why isn't he afraid of push basics  i don't know  but  from these seven assemblies right  was push basics not just winning an  exchange there  okay  maybe a mutual blindness moment from  both players yesterday we saw some  blindness too in the rapport games  okay so